some are calling it a first ever for CNN
no not a ratings win dream on in front
of an audience you can count on your
fingers and toes one anchor gave this
moment of self-reflection I thought a
Vinod it could be a serious candidate
for president so give me a media
critique what was that was that stupid
on my part what do you what do you make
of how a Vinod he was covered by CNN and
MSNBC well if you have to ask now that
my keys been found guilty of extortion
about to go on trial for other crimes
and fuelled the most heinous smears of
Brett Kavanaugh I think the answer is
yes you were stupid and that's putting
it lightly
cuz this mayor Coppola should have
happened a while ago before all the
montages of hacks kissing a vanadis but
had forced your hand and what if he
hadn't been found guilty if he had
walked it would have been right into
cnn's open arms but I should stop I'm
being a jerk see I can self-reflect to
true to the maxim that you should never
mock someone for doing the right thing I
say good job Brian and you too Toobin
the total collapse of his life is really
sort of extraordinary and frankly you
know I feel kind of snookered because I
took him seriously snookered means you
were unfairly tricked that you're the
victim but Geoff why were you fooled
when everyone beyond the media wasn't
was it cuz he wanted to believe Mikey
had the goods on Trump and Cavanaugh no
matter how absurd those Goods were the
media's excuse was that Alvin Adi was
part of the stormy story no they were
looking for a savior not a stripper
after all where is her spotlight now so
the media got snookered cuz like a
remote tribe thinking an empty coke
bottle falling from the sky came from
the gods their desperation made them
credulous so hooray for self reflection
but remember these suckers just spent
three years calling you suckers for
supporting the president so see this as
a rare moment they'll be back on that
horse in no time leaving a trail of
manure wherever they go which makes it
an easy story to follow all right Donna
you agree with me on everything I just
said don't you I'm balanced but why is
it so hard for the media to self-reflect
the media should yeah y'all [ __ ] that's
what human beings do that's what
institutions should
look Michael avenatti came to the DNC
meeting back in 2019
yeah and for my vote yeah and the boats
of other Democrats and many of us look
them looked him up looked him down he
always wore nice suits
just like you Jesse you notice I can
touch you this ain't no off the rack
quality I just touch it and I'm still
bleeding but Michael Abernathy was a
scam artist yeah put it that way okay I
wish you'd get I hope he gets a fair
trial in California but this guy got
over a hundred and seventy five million
dollars worth of free media yep
defendants stormy Daniels going out
there with some other person hmm I'm
speaking of free media you just helped I
want to play some free media and you can
all comment on it this is more of the
obsession with avenatti I think Muller's
not going to take Trump down I think
avenatti is going to take drunk down
because Donald Trump is terrified of
Michael avenatti
lately to me you're like the holy spirit
you are all places at all times
Michael avenatti for president in 2020
he's Donald Trump's worst nightmare mic
on so I don't know who to call on for
this one the Holy Spirit's anybody I'll
take I think it's always important I
always like to question the height like
if there's a lot of hype about something
I guess if it's a movie yeah a novel I
was not going to wait just a minute like
tap the brakes let other people kick the
tires before I would like jump in
because something like this could happen
and he did have scam artists written all
over in a nice suit yeah Emily you're a
lawyer this guy makes your profession
look disgusting
I look at you differently I think what's
so there I've so many troubling aspects
about this but one of them being you
know the total collapse of his life how
it's extraordinary the total collapse
doesn't happen overnight that's like
when you hear about a celebrity or a
star and they're like overnight
sensation but you're like no that
ten years of them sleeping in their car
and go to iTunes 24 hours a day so you
don't get to a 36 count federal
indictment without years
yeah operation on the federal
government's part he isn't paid taxes
since 2010 so the notion and and this
doesn't include by the way the who that
the multiple locks how do you do and you
know there were multiple lawsuits by his
clients as well so all of that is not
only discoverable but it's obvious so
that's number one so the fact that this
is like oh we had no idea right all it
does is speak volumes about them not him
and he should have been vetted and and
and just likewise we need to vet cabinet
members we need to vet people in general
that's why we're vetting Michael
Bloomberg okay
I mean we have to vote we know Bloomberg
we know Trump we didn't know this guy
which leads me to my big question is he
do these guys have any excuse were
saying we were snookered permission to
make it a now it's absolutely granted
the media's like the guy at a bar that
falls in love with the prostitute right
everybody at the bar knows she's a
prostitute and they're all laughing and
they're all warning the guy but the guy
thinks he's in love and the other things
they have a connection and no one really
believes there's a connection there and
he goes upstairs she takes his money he
has a good time but you know what he
learns nothing from it and he does it
again the next month and this is what
happens in the media it's not just a
fanatic it's the dossier it's small ed
its Covington I mean they fell for bado
they think global warming is gonna kill
us in 12 years these people are all
marks and they get taken advantage of by
the CIA by leakers by politicians by
lobbyists if they have the same agenda
as you they just buy the media up and
then they're gone the next day
wading in the waters that's one right
now I might add I might held your hand
on that one No
I think it could've been the media is
being used and they kind of like it
people get pimped all the time you
talked about prostitutes this was a pimp
job
who's running Michael interesting